[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j
bonjour et bienvenue sur 9 7 4 tv avec
nous dans cette belle forêt du maïdo
[Musique]
à mes côtés grégory maillot
organisateurs de la course vélos rent
festival grégory aujourd'hui on va
pédaler un bon jour michael en effet
aujourd'hui nous partons à la découverte
de la première boucle en direction du
tévelave c'est une moc qui fait environ
35 km on profitera de ce parcours pour
comprendre l'aménagement et l'entretien
de ce territoire
je vous présenterai également thomas le
bihan un charbonnier qui exploite une
concession sur cette zone du maïdo
allez suivez nous c'est parti grégory
cette première partie est vraiment une
partie on va dire assez facile hein où
on peut découvrir le maïdo exactement on
va on va traverser avec la grosse
particularité la concession de thomas le
bianchi et charbonnier sur le massif et
puis après de belles pistes en forêt
avec des bambous qu'allumer super bon
débat je te suis allez go
[Musique]
le maïdo est une forêt départementaux
domaniale sa gestion relève des
compétences du département et c'est le
service aménagement et valorisation des
espaces naturels qui gère tout ce
domaine
dans cette direction du département de
la réunion ils sont une quinzaine
d'agents leur mission développer les
projets d'aménagement des espaces
naturels du département
au total près de cent mille hectares de
forêts dont le massif des hauts sous le
vent
un patrimoine qu'il valorise grâce à des
dispositifs d'accueil du public des
activités de découverte et de loisirs le
massif du maïdo est une forêt vraiment
multifonctionnel puisqu'elle regroupe
des enjeux à la fois environnementaux
bien sûr une grande biodiversité au
travers de la forêt primaire de la
tamarinaie des enjeux sociaux la forêt
et les travaux qui sont réalisés en
forêt sont faits pour beaucoup par des
des ouvriers des agents qui sont en
insertion dont c'est un support
d'insertion vienne création d'emplois à
près de 500 sur le l'ensemble du domaine
forestier et puis bien évidemment des
enjeux économiques au travers du
tourisme puisqu'elle offre des activités
de découverte de loisirs de sport très
varié et très prisé de
[Musique]
voilà regrette donc là on a quitté la
route forestière on a fait une partie de
sentiers et on arrive sur une
exploitation de charbon exactement cet
endroit là marquera le début des
hostilités pour les compétiteurs et ce
sera une belle découverte parce qu'on
passera vraiment à côté de cette
exploitation pour ceux qui prendront la
première boucle comme une découverte
comme une balade
ok donc là maintenant on va redescendre
et attaquer la suite du parcours exact
en bon on y va aller la nuit
[Musique]
ici le paysage est saisissant on se
trouve sur la zone de l'incendié de 2011
quelques personnes ont choisi
d'exploiter cette terre brûlée c'est le
cas de thomas le bihan
[Musique]
thomas le bihan et charbonnier à savoir
faire familial transmis de génération en
génération
son grand père et son père avant lui
produisez du charbon artisanale dans ses
anciennes cuves à pétrole thomas est un
jeune entrepreneur qui développe son
activité économique tout en préservant
le patrimoine végétal du maïdo
le médecin charbonnier nos consiste à
fabriquer du charbon à base de bois qui
a brûlé lors d'un incendie du maïdo
on enlève tout le bac a brûlé donc ici a
plus rien donc c'est le bois qu'on
enlève ensuite on enlève aussi les
pestes végétales qui dit acacias et
brasier donc ça aussi c'est super bien
pour faire du charbon et puis bon ben ça
a permis nettoyer dans un premier temps
la forêt pour que l'unef qui seront
plantés une nouvelle génération damas
dans les années qui suivent l'émission
se termine merci à grégory de nous avoir
fait découvrir ses beaux sentiers du
maïdo merci à toi michael et je vous
donne rendez vous le dimanche 10 avril à
trois bassins pour une belle journée au
grand air en famille entre amis
stupeur merci à toute l'équipe merci à
emmanuel alexandre pour les prises de
vue
vous pourrez retrouver ce programme sur
le facebook de 9 7 4 cv à bientôt
[Musique]